pendant toute la journée d'hier il y
avait des petites alertes qui arrivait
des nouvelles comme quoi les forces
ukrainienne auraient repris le contrôle
de tel ou tel village des localités
notamment dans la région de zaporijia au
sud est de la hausse je me trouve
actuellement et dans la région de
kherson plus au sud est mais ce sont des
avancées très petit temps ce sont des
petits villages que les français
n'arrivent selon eux parfois c'est
confirmé aussi par des experts
militaires américains à reprendre il y a
eu aussi des avancées dans le nord mais
ce qu'il ne faut pas oublier c'est que
les attaques aériennes à différents
endroits du pays où les roquettes tirées
à longue distance continue les russes
avaient toujours dit qu'il continuerait
à cibler des cibles militaires un peu à
travers tout le cren notamment des
dépôts de pétrole hier matin c'était au
tour de dnipro de voir un petro un dépôt
de pétrole dans la région de nippes aux
attaques et est très substantiellement
détruites et puis hier même dans kiev
pas loin du centre de kiev en réalité il
y a eu deux explosions
on ignore pour le moment si c'était des
tirs de roquettes ou des explosions dues
à un sabotage ou tout simplement à un
accident la militaire ukrainien ne
veulent pas informé sur la question mais
en tout cas c'était près du centre de
kiev et l'ue des ambulances vie a vu
près du site